pour cette manie coise la voiture est
indispensable mais après plus de 40 ans
de conduite elle sait que ses
connaissances ne sont plus les mêmes et
passer mon prof dans 1971 et donc je
pense qu'il ya une très nette évolution
et je vais me remettre au goût du jour
parce que je roule quand même pas mal
et puis bon je pense qu'on en a besoin
passé un certain âge de se remettre en
question et de voir qu'est ce qu'il nous
reste une remise au goût du jour à
l'hôtel de ville
magny les hameaux organise un atelier
code de la route à destination des
seniors
au programme des rappels et les
nouvelles réglementations de 2015 et
c'était aussi nous demande de la police
municipale la force de patrouiller les
constatation de l'infraction
voilà on s'aperçoit aussi que les règles
de base sont complètement oubliés ou ou
soixante carrément habitudes et les
ateliers conte on arrive à avoir ces
vingt trente personnes
exceptionnellement et là on est à plus
de 50 personnes
donc c'est vraiment une réelle demande
des seniors et la plupart conduisons
ceux qui sont là en france 17 % de la
population a plus de 65 ans une
catégorie d'âge sur représentés dans les
chiffres de la sécurité routière